>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Michel Martin: So you might ask
yourself why numbers are important
in the life of a man of letters,
but I'd like to share with you some
of the numbers that struck me when
I was thinking about Ernest Gaines.
The fifth generation born
on a Louisiana plantation.
The oldest of 12 children
wrote his first book
at 17 while babysitting one
of those other 12 children.
Four of his works made into movies.
What are they?
>>Autobiography of Jane Pittman.
>> Michel Martin: That's it.
Autobiography of Ms. Jane Pittman.
What else?
[ Inaudible ]
>> Michel Martin: Gathering
of old -- yeah, there it is.
Winner of most of this country's
highest literary honors.
Yeah.
[ Applause ]
See, I don't want you to think
that applause was for me,
because I'm about to
introduce myself.
I'm Michelle Martin, weekend host,
Of All Things Considered
within PR News.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
And I am delighted
and so honored to be
in conversation with Ernest Gaines.
During the 2017 Library of Congress
National Book Festival he is here
on the occasion of the
publication of his latest book,
The Tragedy of Brady Sims,
his first in two decades.
Thank you so much for
being here with us.
[ Applause ]
>> And thank you all for being here.
And as I said braving the rain.
I was asked to for just a
couple of housekeeping issues,
could you please silence
your phones.
We are, as you can see
live streaming this,
and so if you could
please silence your phones.
We are going to talk
up here for a bit,
but we will definitely
take your questions.
I will try to give
you enough notice,
so it's not a fitness contest.
I was asked to let you know
that if you do ask a question,
you will be part of our
broadcast here, so if you are shy
or if you wanted to put
your invisible suit on,
you're out of luck.
Sorry. And with all that being said,
welcome once again Ernest Gaines.
>> Ernest Gaines: Thank you.
>> Michel Martin: We
love you so much.
[ Applause ]
Well, first of all, you know,
I have to with all this rain,
and I promise you we didn't arrange
it just so you feel more welcome.
But how is your house?
How are things in your hometown
with all this weather doings?
Is everything okay?
>> Ernest Gaines: Well, rain, you
know, rain is like that every year.
>> Michel Martin: Yeah.
But everything's okay?
>> Ernest Gaines: Everything's okay.
Yeah. We, were not
flooded out at all.
>> Michel Martin: Well,
that's a blessing.
We're really glad that you made it.
We was worried that you
might not be able to.
You know, you said you were done.
In an interview that I found
with the New York Times in 2010,
you said that you had
nothing original left to say.
Do you remember saying that?
>> Ernest Gaines: No, I don't.
>> Michel Martin: [laughs] You
don't remember saying that?
[laughs]
>> Ernest Gaines: No.
>> Michel Martin: What
made you decide
that you did have more to say?
>> Ernest Gaines: Well,
I don't know.
One day I woke up and I thought
about writings and things, and,
[inaudible] which was originally
titled "The Man with Children."
And thought about why
as a man with children.
There was about three men on
this plantation where I grew up
and they all sort of looked
after the children [inaudible]
and that was to keep the children
out of jail, and keep the children
out of trouble with
the law and sheriff.
And especially keeping children
from ever going to Angola,
so they knew any other way
to control the children.
What had happened, this
would be part of the --
well, during the war when the
military took the young man
into service, and most
of the other people
at the same time you have the
tractors taking over the work
that many had done with, you
know, mill and plow and so many
of the people were sort
of pushed off the land,
because they had no work there.
And the children was
left with the old people
until people got established
someplace in the town or north
or east or wherever west.
My people went to the West
Coast and I went to California
at an early age, age 15 I went to
California to study, to educate.
And many of the as I say the
younger children were left
with the old people, and some
of the old people could
not control the children,
and so they got somebody to
help them, and it was that man
who love children and
had put all of his --
three men I knew who did this on
this plantation I made them all
into this one man, Brady Sims.
So he is the man that
whipped children.
>> Michel Martin: And
when you say "whipped,"
you don't mean a stern talking to?
You don't mean don't do that?
>> Ernest Gaines: No,
no, no, no, no, no.
>> Michel Martin: Don't
do that again.
>> Ernest Gaines: No,
I mean a switch.
I'm in a switch, and
then at the time you had
to break your own switch, you
know, go out and break it.
And you come back and
give you your punishment.
>> Michel Martin: The book starts
with something quite shocking.
Do you want to tell it or
do you want me to tell it?
>> Ernest Gaines: Well, I thought --
>> Michel Martin: No,
I'm going to reach up to.
I'll take you up there.
>> Ernest Gaines: Oh, you're
going to take me up there?
>> Michel Martin: The book
starts in the courtroom
where a young man who's
just been sentenced
for a terrible crime
has just been shot.
A man, an elderly man stands up
in the courtroom, and shoots him.
And then the sheriff for
whatever reason, he says,
"You know what, I need two hours.
Tell them to come get
me in two hours."
And they let him go for two hours.
And the young -- it turns out
that the man had shot his own son.
>> Ernest Gaines: Yeah.
Right. I could have
read that [inaudible].
>> Michel Martin: Okay.
[ Laughs ]
>> Michel Martin: So, you know, it's
actually -- do you want to read now?
>> Ernest Gaines: Read a little bit.
>> Michel Martin: Here you go.
All right.
He said because you're
messing it up.
>> Ernest Gaines: You better.
>> Michel Martin: You're
messing it up.
[Applause] You're not doing it.
Here you go.
Oh, you want to read
from the beginning?
Okay.
>> Ernest Gaines: No,
the beginning and --
>> Michel Martin: Okay.
>> Ernest Gaines: Chapter one.
We don't want to do
the whole chapter now.
[ Laughs ]
>> Ernest Gaines: "It was over.
We all got up to leave.
Two deputies had the
prisoner by the arm.
I was sitting in the back of the
courthouse, because I had been
on another assignment and
I had gotten there late.
I was near the aisle
when I heard someone call
out loud and clear, Boy.
I looked back over
my shoulder and saw
that the two deputies had
stopped with their prisoner
and were facing old Brady Sims.
Next came the loudest sound
that I had ever heard.
I saw the prisoner fall back with
blood splashed from his body,
and both deputies let go of
his arms at the same time.
Brady Sims stood there in
that old faded blue jumper
with the smoke still rising
from the gun in his hand.
Then came the screaming, and the
scrambling to get out of the place.
I'll get down on the floor.
The members of the jury who
didn't run out of the room got
down behind their chairs.
The judge went under his desk.
The two deputies stood frozen
with their hands near the
guns, but not on the guns.
Brady raising them, his head as
white as cotton is in September,
stood as straight and tall
as a picket in a fence.
I watched him.
I watched them all afraid to run,
afraid to get down on the floor."
"Tell mates, give me
two hours," Brady said.
"Now you don't think you're walking
out of here, do you," Claude said.
"He was the younger
of the two deputies.
Brady got his head off
the chair next to the one
where he had been sitting.
He adjusted well on
that pile of cotton."
"I didn't come here for no
foolishness, boy," he said.
"Tell me what I said.
He said to Russell, the order
deputy, go on," Russell said,
"Go on like hell, go
on," Claude said.
"Then I heard that definite
sound again and the smoke rising
up between the old man
and the two deputies."
>> Michel Martin: All right.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Michel Martin: You know, this is
obviously a very particular place
and not quite clear when, but
it's very current in some ways
because it's very much about it,
well, it's about a lot of things.
It's about there's a whole question
of the way law enforcement treats
young black men, which is very much
on people's minds right now.
And increasingly if you saw the
video yesterday of that incident
in Salt Lake City, it's also the way
law enforcement treats everybody.
No disrespect to law
enforcement here.
We appreciate you, but that's
very much on people's minds.
But it's also about how black
people treat each other.
Do you want to talk a
little but about that?
>> Ernest Gaines: Now
if I could read it.
>> Michel Martin: Here I'm
going to ask you the part.
Can you read my part?
Read my part.
>> Ernest Gaines: I'll
read your part, yeah.
>> Michel Martin: Then
read the part I like.
>> Ernest Gaines: Okay.
Good.
>> Michel Martin: We're sharing.
We're not really directing,
we're sharing.
This part is the one I like.
Okay.
>> Ernest Gaines: "Jamison went
on one Sunday after church.
Tyree told the people
not to leave yet.
He had been getting
complaints that children,
the old people couldn't control.
The mamas and the poppers had
gone to war or up north for work,
leaving the children
with the old people.
The children stayed in
trouble, always going to jail.
Some going to Angola.
They brought up mobile.
For an example what happened
went they went to Angola,
and they didn't want to see
that happen to their children.
They wanted Tyree to
tell them what to do.
Tyree told that if they couldn't
control the children get somebody
on the place who could, but who?
Then they came up with
Brady, Brady Sims.
Brady could stop them.
None of the Brady's kids
ever got into trouble.
Brady was the man to do the job.
They went to Brady.
Brady said if that's what
they wanted, he would do it.
They said that's what they wanted.
And they warned their
children, keep it up.
Keep it up.
Just keep it up, you will meet
with Mr. Brady, Mr. Brady's whip.
Jamison looked back
at Lucas [inaudible].
You still with me, Lucas?
You're mighty quiet back
there in that chair.
I'm with you all the way, man.
Lucas [inaudible] said,
you're telling it to a T.
>> Michel Martin: Thank you.
Beautiful.
[ Applause ]
>> Michel Martin: Did anyone
of you all meet a Brady Sims
when you were growing up?
Did any of you all meet
a Brady Sims, a whipper?
Were any of you all hit as kids?
[laughs] I'm not the only one here.
Am I the only one telling
the truth up in here?
>> Ernest Gaines: We had
it in school at that time.
You know, your teacher had the
authority to whip the children,
and [inaudible] of the
children and do their lesson
or if they did something
wrong, that's it.
They [inaudible] or made
noise or did something.
The teachers controlled
them at that time.
I'm talking about the
40s, the 50s, you know.
>> Michel Martin: Did
you ever get the switch?
>> Ernest Gaines: Oh, yeah.
Fighting, and the teacher
would whip you.
And they would make you
open your hand out to them
and they would have you
with the ruler and pop, pop,
pop both hands like this.
So we went to all of that.
>> Michel Martin: You have a
deep sympathy it seems to me
for everybody involved
in the situation.
I mean, you have sympathy for the
kids, but you also have sympathy
for the ones doing the
whipping, it seems to me.
>> Ernest Gaines: Well,
I'm God, my people.
No matter what you all are, I have
sympathy for you and God loves all
of us, whether we're
criminals or saints down here.
So I have love for all of my
characters, whatever I create.
You know, a mean guy, and
Brady Sims can be awful mean.
You know, of course I have
great sympathy for Brady,
just as I have sympathy for
the other adults, everybody.
I sure love my people,
I love my characters.
>> Michel Martin: One time
a interviewer said to you,
"There is a high price
attached to bravery."
And you said, "I like
pride in people.
I try to show the strength
of black people."
You are showing the
price of that strength.
Does that seem right?
>> Ernest Gaines: The price
of that strength, in what way?
>> Michel Martin: The price of what
sometimes it takes for people to be
who they are, that there is
a price attached to that.
>> Ernest Gaines: Yeah.
I look at like my characters.
Anyone who when you say "brave,"
they go beyond a certain
point, a line.
A line is drawn for you by your own
people as well as the law out there.
And you cross that line
then you get punished.
You get punished.
You usually get punished when
you question the old people
about why do I have to do this.
And of course you get
punished by the, you know,
the white law out there as well,
that when you do something
really punished.
And that's why the people to try to
keep the people from doing anything,
to keep the people
from going to Angola.
>> Michel Martin: Angola
being the prison there.
A lot of you heard of that.
>> Ernest Gaines: That's the number
one -- Angola during the 40s the 40s
and 50s was the worst
prison in this country,
state prison in this country.
It's in state prison
in Louisiana, Angola.
>> Michel Martin: I don't know if
any of you grew up with this notion,
I'm beating you because I
don't want them to kill you.
Do any of you grow up with that
hearing, I'm going to beat you
because I don't want that one
out there, the police, the law,
the white society to kill you.
And I think that's -- do you
think that's still with us?
Do you think that attitude
is still here?
>> Ernest Gaines: Oh, I think so.
You know, to a certain degree.
I don't think about it
[inaudible] well I don't know.
But I think they will do
anything to keep children from,
you know, going to prison.
They're simply going to stop them.
>> Michel Martin: Well,
let's open up.
Why don't you start
thinking about what it is
that you might want to talk about.
You see there are two microphones.
There's one here, and there is
one here, and then we'll take
as many questions as we can.
I'll give you a chance -- we'll
talk a little bit more up here
and give you a chance
to come up to the mics,
and we'll talk a little
bit more as long as we can.
And also I want to mention that
there's a book signing after this
from 12:00 to 1:00, I believe
wherever it is they are doing
book signings.
I think that's on the first floor.
And can I ask you about your --
while folks are getting
ready to ask their questions.
What is your take on the whole
question of Black Lives Matter.
And the way that a lot of young
folks these days are engaging
with not just young people, but
mainly they're kind of at the front
of this engaging with law
enforcement right now.
Many of them are saying
that they're kind of tired
of the traditional approaches that
people in our generation have used
to engage on these questions.
Like, you know, protests
and things like that.
So they're saying, you know,
they've had it with that.
They don't feel like we're making
enough progress, and I just wondered
if you have thoughts about that?
>> Ernest Gaines: No, I don't
understand what they're saying.
I say Black Lives Matter of course.
What else do they have to
say but black lives matter?
I don't know what those kids, youth
you're talking about is saying.
I don't know how they're
going to protest.
I don't know what they're talking
about they're talking about.
Yeah. Do you have a question, sir?
>> Michel Martin: Sir.
>> Frasier O'Leary: Hi, my name
is Frasier O'Leary, and I teach
or I just retired from teaching
at Codozo High School
here in the district.
And Mr. Gaines came to my class in
1993 to talk to my students as part
of the Penn Faulkner
Writers in Schools Program.
I don't know if he remembers.
I know the students do.
And I don't have a question.
I just have a comment that I've been
teaching a lesson before [inaudible]
since 1993 to my students
at Cardozo,
and it's always had an
incredible impact on their lives.
And I just wanted to thank
you so much for honoring us
with your visit back in 1993.
>> Ernest Gaines: Where is this?
>> Frasier O'Leary: At
Cardozo High School here in DC.
>> Ernest Gaines: Oh, yeah, yeah.
>> Frasier O'Leary:
You came to the class.
>> Ernest Gaines: Okay.
>> Frasier O'Leary: And the students
got the book before it was even
in the book stands,
the hardback copy.
I still have mine.
You have to sign it today.
[ Laughs ]
>> Frasier O'Leary: But I just
wanted to thank you for all
of our students for making such
an impression on their lives.
>> Ernest Gaines: Thank
you very much, sir.
>> Frasier O'Leary:
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> Michel Martin: Thank
you for that.
There's some questions
coming up here.
You can come here.
There's a lady here
who has a question.
>> Actually, it's not a
question, and I just wanted
to let Mr. Gaines know
that my book club,
the African American
Discussion Group
in Rockville Memorial
Library read his book,
discussed his book
on October 16, 2014.
There were about 15 of us.
Everybody loved the book.
The biggest argument was whether
or not the teacher was the one
who got the lesson as opposed
to the person he was
supposed to be teaching.
And some of us argued that he did
teach the doomed boy something,
and the rest of the said no, it
was the teacher who got the lesson.
[laughs]
>> Ernest Gaines: Well both.
>> Both, okay.
Thank you.
>> Ernest Gaines: The
teacher until he --
Jefferson realized he was a
human being, was running in.
He wasn't really teaching
until he reached Jefferson,
and then Jefferson's a prisoner.
And then he realized that now I
am, you know, he was surprised
that he had taught anything,
as he hated teaching.
But after visiting Jefferson
in jail over and over and over,
and he saw this person who thought
he was an animal as described
by the lawyer, changing from that
kind of person to a, you know,
a real human he realized that
by doing that for Jefferson,
Jefferson had also helped him.
By helping Jefferson,
Jefferson helped him.
>> Michel Martin: Thank you.
And here.
>> Thank you.
Mr. Gaines, do you have
a favorite of your books?
>> Ernest Gaines: Do I
have a favorite book?
>> Yeah. A favorite
of your own books,
which one would you recommend to us?
>> Ernest Gaines: Oh, I
don't have a favorite book.
I have a favorite short story.
>> Okay.
>> Ernest Gaines: Of mine, and that
is Christ Walked Down Market Street.
I don't have a favorite
now both, no.
And I guess Christ Walked Down
Market Street is my favorite story.
And it's the oldest story that
I written about California.
Everything else has been written
about as a Louisiana background,
but one story, Christ Walked
Down Market Street is
my favorite short story.
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Ernest Gaines: I could say
one thing more about that story.
It is a man who meets Christ
twice, and never recognizes it.
And then he has done, so each time.
He always recognize and
after they have separated,
but he meets him twice, and
that's what my story is about.
>> Dr. Gaines, in reading
your books one character
that I see represented strongly
is a teacher in each case.
And I like to hear you talk about
your experience with teachers
that brought them into a
prominent role in your writing.
>> Michel Martin: Oh, I
have to say in this book,
the character it's a journalist,
and were very happy about that.
[ Laughs ]
>> And I will be reading
that one next.
[laughs]
>> Ernest Gaines: What role
does the teachers play in --
>> Your life.
>> Ernest Gaines: -- in my life.
Well, I guess that's why I'm
here today, because of teachers
in my life whom taught me
writing and taught me everything.
Other than your home I think
the teacher is the next greatest
influence on a student,
especially young people.
So that's why there's
always some teaching,
somebody's teaching somebody
in my books, I suppose.
>> Michel Martin: Sir.
>> Yes. Dr. Gaines, my mother
was from Pointe Coupee,
and she moved to [inaudible]
for high school.
Then we lived in the St.
Bernard projects until seven
and moved to Los Angeles.
Before moving to Los
Angeles my whole world
in that area was black and Catholic.
I went to Los Angeles
in south-central,
the Catholic school became more
than black and all the religions
in my area be mostly black
was I think Catholic.
It gave me a whole
new take on the world.
As two things, one, what's
special about Pointe Coupee?
I've never visited it
in your background,
and what events gave
you a broader prospect
of the world other
than in that area?
>> Ernest Gaines: You say what
is special about Pointe Coupee?
>> Pointe Coupee, and then what
leaving there gave you a more world
view just about people in general?
>> Ernest Gaines: Well I've lived --
my first 15 years of my life
is spent in Pointe Coupee.
Of five generations of my people
lived there from slavery to,
you know, and I still have people
in Pointe Coupee Parish,
so it is my home.
It is my home, and much more than
my home than any other place,
any other part of the state
or in the part of the country.
You know, the church, well, after
we moved, after we bought a piece
of property on that plantation, my
wife and I, we moved a little church
from the water to our property,
and so to hang onto our history.
I went to the little
church as a child
and I was taught there my first six
years, six grade, six, seven, eight,
sixth grade, yes as a child
in that little church.
That is my entire world the
Parish of Pointe Coupee Parish.
>> Thank you.
>> Michel Martin: Hi.
>> Hi. Dr. Gaines, I grew up in
Louisiana, and there's a part of one
of your books that really changed
my view of things of Louisiana,
particular part in
my father's house.
I'm just curious, and I know
that I've heard you've been asked
a couple of political questions.
It doesn't seem to be your
primary interest, but I'm curious
if you think in Louisiana right
now we look at Mitch Landrieu
and New Orleans taking the monuments
down, and those kind of actions.
Do you think anything's changing
deeply in Louisiana toward a view
of rethinking the past that you're
thinking of from the point of view
of really taking an
honest look at that past?
>> Ernest Gaines: You know, I never
did notice those little statues.
[laughs] I never seen them.
I went by them, but it had
no effect on me at all.
And I think taking them down now,
not that I'm against
taking them down.
>> Sure.
>> Ernest Gaines: But what's
happening now that's really
separating people much more
than when they were there.
I never did, you know, I don't
think my younger, my siblings
or my older people thought
much of those statues.
They just didn't think about it.
But it's a contemporary
feeling by the young people.
And Jefferson once said
that every generation,
there's a change every generation.
>> Right.
>> Ernest Gaines: I mean 20 years
and they have the right to complain
about this, but personally
I haven't been affected
by the statute being
they are not there.
>> Right. Thank you.
>> Ernest Gaines: But I know
it's happening in a sense
that not taking them down you can
feel this tension now is growing
between the races there.
>> Yeah.
>> Ernest Gaines: In my area.
>> Thank you.
>> Dr. Gaines, I know how in the
Autobiography of Miss Jane Pittman,
it was published that you have
been asked whether it was fiction
or whether it was real,
and you were saying that,
you know, people were confused.
And you came and said, "No, I did
not interview people for this.
These people were my creations."
I want to report to you an odd
occurrence that I had when teaching
at a middle school in
Frederick many years ago
that the social studies
teacher there was one
of the many confused
people you had heard about,
and she had presented the novel
to her students as a real piece
of primary evidence, and
didn't realize it was fiction.
In fact, the students themselves
kind of wondered and looked it up
and caught on that in fact it was
fiction, and when they spoke to her
about it she was very
irate and denied it.
I came to know of it, and
she told them, you know,
"How dare you question me."
So some of those students came to me
for confirmation, and I said, "Well,
yes, it's fiction," and then
they told me what was going on.
At the end of the day
I just had lunch
with her very quietly
one time, and said that,
you know really it was a work
of fiction, and, you know,
you should probably think
of something you should
say to your students.
But I wonder how do you react to
such a thing going on, fiction
and reality and how
the two of them --
>> Ernest Gaines: Well, I when
that book first came out, you know,
a lot of people thought it was
a real person, and Ruby Dee,
the actress wrote in the I think
"Black World," reviewed the book
for "Black World," and she
reviewed it as a real person,
several others did the same.
I think it was CBS, one of the
national radio stations called me
on the phone and wanted to know,
they wanted a picture of Mrs. Jane,
[laughs] so I had to explain she
was not, she was just a creation,
my creation by my imagination.
But we've had that
since the beginning.
I just didn't know I could create
a character that could be so real,
and that people would think
that she was actually based
on a live person, but she was not.
I've never known one Miss Jane.
I've never in my life
known one Miss Jane,
but I've known a thousand Miss Jane.
See this is no one but
a thousand of them,
because every time I see
a little old lady walking
down the street that's Miss Jane.
That's Miss Jane to me.
>> Thank you.
>> Ernest Gaines: Thank you, ma'am.
>> Hi, Mr. Gaines.
I was one of your students at the
University of Louisiana Lafayette,
and one of your neighbors.
I'm Lisa Gornick, and I
just want to thank you.
I know that you inspired me and a
cohort of graduate students who were
in Louisiana in the
90s to be passionate
about teaching and
about our students.
And my question to you is
about your wife, Diane's work
and how it's influenced you to look
at the populations that you looked
at with the prison system?
>> Ernest Gaines: I'm
sorry I didn't.
>> Michel Martin: She's asking
you about your wife, Diane.
>> Ernest Gaines: Yes.
>> Michel Martin: Her work has
influenced you in some way,
and she also of course wanted to
thank you as an aspiring teacher.
>> Ernest Gaines: Oh.
>> Michel Martin: And she
was one of your students.
>> Ernest Gaines: I heard that part.
[ Laughs ]
>> Michel Martin: And we're going
to have time for one more question,
after this sir, I think
you have a question.
We're going to have time for one
more question after this answer.
>> Ernest Gaines: I don't know
how my wife had influenced me
in any way in writing.
She likes my writing.
That's enough.
[ Laughs ]
>> Ernest Gaines: Thank you.
>> Michel Martin: Sir.
>> All right.
Good morning, Dr. Gaines.
You spoke about the fear of
the youth going to Angola.
I wanted to know if you could
describe the impact of Angola
on the community that you
grew up in as a child?
>> Ernest Gaines: Well I've seen
people who've gone to Angola,
and broken -- I mean,
physically and mentally broken.
And I've seen people who have come
back from Angola who were more mean,
more mean or more worse than
they were before they went in.
I don't know.
I mean I seen people broken down,
and then made more of
a monster by Angola.
But the old people
were just against,
and those were the
ones that came back.
Many of them never did come back.
They were sentenced
there for a longer period
of time and they died there.
But I'd say they stayed five
years or they were broken.
They were broken one way or another,
be more cruel toward their own
people or, you know, to anybody
or really become nothing like but
a, you know, helpless creature.
You ever seen that?
>> Michel Martin: Before we
let you go, and we're thankful,
so thankful that you are here.
We are thankful for your work.
I was asked to say that
again there's a book signing
from 12:00 to 1:00.
It's where all the
book signings are.
I think it's on the first floor.
When you exit if you could use
that door, the one that's closest
to the stage where we are
now, it would help the folks
who are managing this room.
Dr. Gaines, one more
question for you from me.
A lot of us, a lot of people,
just let me just put it
this way are wondering
about what they should
be doing right now.
You spoke of meanness.
Many have observed that
we are in a mean moment.
That a lot of our public
discourse is mean.
A lot of our politics is mean, and
I wondered if you have some thoughts
about how you would wish
us to meet this moment.
I know we all have our work.
Your work is as a writer.
A lot of us do different work.
Do you have thoughts about
what people should do right now
in the current moment, when you
lived through mean moments before.
>> Ernest Gaines: You know
those questions have been asked
since the beginning of
time, what should people do.
And what can people do
but try to, you know,
get along with other persons, the
person around him or around her.
I have no answer to that.
I can't answer that question.
I just, you know,.
>> Michel Martin: You do you.
You do your thing.
>> Ernest Gaines: I'm sorry.
>> Michel Martin: You do your thing.
>> Ernest Gaines: You do your thing.
You just try to live the best you
can with the people around you.
I cannot tell you how to live.
I will not try to tell anyone how to
live, because I don't know exactly.
I know how I live, but what can
I tell you to live the way I do.
>> Michel Martin: Well,
thank you for this book.
Do you have another one in you?
You said you got up one morning
and just started writing.
You got another one?
You're going to get up tomorrow
around another one for us?
>> Ernest Gaines: Well I
have intended to write.
This is a novella really,
and rather than a full novel.
And in the beginning I
wanted to write two novellas
to make it a hardback
book, but this small book.
So that's the next project I
have, and I will go back home
and start back over it again.
It's about the same
length as this one.
The title is The Daughters
of the Creole Lady.
And I've been playing with that
a long, long time, that title
and that subject for a long time.
So that's my next project.
Let's hope I can get it done this
time, because I really wanted
to [inaudible] at the same type
as this one to make it hardback.
>> Michel Martin: Okay.
Well we like this one.
>> Ernest Gaines: Thank
you very much.
>> Michel Martin: Ernest Gaines.
[Applause].
His latest book, The
Tragedy of Brady Sims.
Thank you both.
Thank you so much for being here.
Thank you.